foreign
everyone my name is Dr Miller and the
SCP we're going to be looking at today
is
scp-2002 object class neutralized ketter
classification revoked
special containment procedures
containment of scp-2002 is to
concentrate on the coordinated
dissemination of misinformation to all
organizations and individuals concerned
with the discovery tracking study and or
discussion of mobile astronomical
objects special focus is to be put on
the manipulation of relevant Fringe
organizations in order to obfuscate the
nature of scp-2002
images of scp-2002 leak to the public in
any manner are to be dismissed as
digitally altered and to be labeled the
work of conspiracy theorists to this
purpose Foundation employed experts are
to be put forward for appearances in
related media and as consultants for any
external research projects
for more information concerning specific
current past and future disinformation
campaigns please refer to documents SEC
inf202d
depdi rev 2.41 use of deadly force has
been authorized in order to keep
information concerning scp-2002 from
being publicized in any way
all collected wreckage of scp-2002 and
the remains of its crew are to be housed
at site 102 for further research into
scp-2002's Origins please contact
project late Dr signoff for more
information on this project
signo 120 million 60
217. please note that despite the
neutralization of scp-2002 these
containment procedures are to stay in
effect indefinitely
description
scp-2002 was a space-faring vessel on a
direct Collision Course with Earth
following detection Foundation deep
space assets managed to relay several
images indicating numerous similarities
between scp-2002's design and Designs
under development
established at that time in light of
this and taking into account data
collected from its wreckage
scp-2002 was classified as a temporal
continuity anomaly but was considered
native to this reality iteration its
neutralization has prevented project
staff from verifying this though
examination of scp-2002 wreckage has
yielded evidence supporting this Theory
scp-2002 had a spherical Hull with an
estimated diameter of 450 meters
attached to this main hall were around 3
000 smaller spheres with an approximate
diameter of 1.7 meters
scp-2002 did not show any visible
propulsion devices or external systems
for power generation nor were individual
compartments or systems such as a
cockpit living quarters storage hold Etc
discernible
all attempts at communication using
Foundation seti installations were
answered by an automated broadcast from
scp-2002 on a radio frequency
specifically reserved for foundation
traffic
signals sent by non-foundation
installations did not elicit a response
from scp-2002 suggesting an awareness of
the hailing Signal's origin please see
addendum
2002a04 for a transcript of this
automated broadcast
on review the message broadcast by
scp-2002 appeared to imply that scp-2002
possessed systems to facilitate a return
to Earth unaided regardless scp-202 was
classified as ketter due to the
potential effects of its Landing should
this assumption prove false
scp-2002 maintained a steady velocity of
12.5 kilometers per second and was
expected to enter Earth's atmosphere on
20 protocols for dealing with any
possible k-class scenario as a result of
scp-2002's return were drafted
scp-202 was first detected at a position
roughly 15.8 astronomical units from
Earth on 19th by remote sensing systems
aboard Foundation satellites
extrapolating from scp-2002's course and
assuming no alterations to that course
scp-2002 should have been discovered at
least years earlier this suggests an
accidental temporal shift rather than a
conscious attempt on the part of
scp-2002 or its crew the content of
scp-2002's automated broadcast lends
further Credence to this Theory
addendum 2002 a01 excerpt from
neutralization report 2002 d n e u t r p
t o one Rev 1.01
on 19 as scp-2002 passed Earth's moon a
previously unidentified Global occult
Coalition satellite containing a
high-powered carbon dioxide laser opened
fire on scp-2002 breaking up the main
Hull and dispersing the smaller spheres
over a wide area several of these were
subsequently destroyed by further laser
fire though most were set adrift in
space when the main Hull was ruptured a
number of smaller spheres continued onto
Earth
these and a large section of the hull
entered Earth's atmosphere
investigations into the global occult
coalitions on warrant the destruction of
scp-2002 uncovered a series of encrypted
email messages transmitted from a
workstation in site 102's Communications
terminal decryption of these messages
uncovered an information linked to the
GOC covering scp-2002 though only in
basic detail in several cases internal
misinformation was leaked in addition to
factually correct data on scp-2002
a comprehensive investigation by mobile
task force beta 1 cauterizers identified
the sender of the messages as a level
four member of research Personnel
employed in site 102 but not attached to
the scp-2002 project the Personnel in
question was detained trying to leave
site 102's compound interrogated and
consequently active use in
counter-intelligence operations efforts
to ascertain the identity of these
specific recipient have been
unsuccessful but it is assumed to be a
Handler for the global occult Coalition
Foundation assets within that
organization have since confirmed that
the organization possessed knowledge of
scp-2002 as early as 19th though only
covering very basic details see below it
is assumed that the lack of detailed and
factually correct information in
addition to the foundation's policy of
internal and external misinformation
with respect to scp-2002 to their
decision to attempt the neutralization
of scp-2002
as a result of this incident protocols
for internal and external communication
concerning anomalies have been reviewed
and were necessary updated and operation
carbon was launched remaining in effect
indefinitely until such time as a
standardized loyalty test can be
developed for current and future
personnel
the satellite employed by the global
occult Coalition was eventually
sabotaged and crashed into the Brazilian
Rainforest on 20. it was recovered by
Foundation forces and remains in
Foundation custody despite numerous
Global occult Coalition requests for its
return please refer to supplemental
documentation 2002 C dip Inc 8 colon rev
0.1.12 for more details regarding
inter-organizational communication on
this subject
addendum
2002a02 capture GOC documentation on
scp-2002
kte 0481
threat ID
kte0481 Typhon large unknown object on a
collision course with Earth
authorized response level 4. severe
threat description an unidentified
unnatural astronomical object on a
collision course with Earth intelligence
provided by covert operator suggests the
foundation is tracking the kte under the
designation
scp-2002 for unknown reasons it has not
initiated any concrete action nor
implemented measures to Halt its
progress please refer to appendix 116
for field reports from covert operator
on available intelligence concerning
this kte
the object is a sphere with an estimated
diameter of 450 meters approximately
1476 feet with a multitude of smaller
spherical nodes attached to it for
unknown purposes it cannot be ruled out
that these nodes are weapon systems no
propulsion systems are directly visible
on the object systems for power
generation seem likewise absent
object does not respond to attempts at
communication despite handling messages
sent at regular intervals by
ground-based doc installations and the
USS
current calculations put time of impact
at GMT
20. conservative Fallout projections
predict an eternal winter class scenario
should
kte0481 be allowed to continue its path
unhindered
Rules of Engagement should the object
come within
0.00269 astronomical units of Earth
termination is warranted to prevent the
extinction of all life on Earth GOC
orbital asset Thor a12 has been put on a
permanent state of alert to this end
protocols have been put in place to
assure a 100 success rate covert
operative is to be extracted immediately
after successful termination of kte 0481
addendum 2002 a03 management summary of
recovery report 2002
drecrpt 14 rev version 1.15
on 20 37 minutes after a large portion
of scp-2002's main Hull and a selection
of smaller spheres touched down members
of mobile task force Zeta 40 Dead End
Cleaners and several local guides
approached the wreckage at approximately
240 kilometers from the Saudi Arabian
capital of Riyadh over the course of
several days all debris and large
selection of partially destroyed human
remains estimated to comprise five adult
males 142 newborn infant males 21 adult
females and 377 newborn infant females
were loaded onto Foundation transports
and taken back to site-102 DNA testing
has revealed partial matches to current
Foundation Personnel including several
members of the o5 council
addendum
2002a04 automated broadcast by 2002.
this is the foundation vessel scps
Mendel we have received your
transmission due to stasis protocols in
effect no members of personnel are
currently available to respond to your
signal
please stand by for our pre-recorded
automated broadcast
this is Dr
giving this message I'm glad to say this
mission was unnecessary when the fall
off from SCP file contain a bridge
heading 21. we spent a long time trying
to find ways to circumvent its effects
first we tried to see if relocation was
the solution we constructed an orbital
and when that didn't work a little
facility but that always followed
somehow faced with a 100 sterility rate
we found that there was a way of
fertilizing embryos so that they
wouldn't be subject to the Plank's
effect at least not while we remained in
stasis our calculations indicated a
dissipation of effects approximately
years from Day Zero so in the end we
were left with no option but to send a
selection of these embryos out into
space along with a crew of personnel
tasked with their care this wrestles
crew and cargo will be revived and
prepared for a return to Earth
they've come a long way
our ETA is currently set at warning
temporal dislocation error detected
we urge you to clear sector 521a for our
arrival
after repetition in Mandarin the message
was also repeated in Spanish Hindi and
Arabic before the transmission ended
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
and you're all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
zargaron
oh crop guy
the Morrigan
James Samba
braided Peach
that loser
heroin sick
Richard broadhurst
fire of prime
Indy versus the world
rubbish bin 69.
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
signor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
and Lost Boy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you